citizens of the reject Nation we are
back here today because we got ourselves
a trailer another one for this is a
flash so of course join with John
Humphrey John how are you I am super
excited sir Koi Koi chandro flashtastic
ready to go follow koi on social media
he lives and breathes it like a
monstrosity what is that thing called in
Man of Steel again my God the world
engine he is like the world engine just
sucking up all the hate comments all the
real supervillains if you can do me a
solid just to be a great favor if you
could just do this for me if you could
speed on over to that like button and
just like the flash that would be
amazing I'm so excited for this movie
because James Gunn will not stop talking
about it speaking of James Gunn and
Guardians of the Galaxy I'm
transitioning here ladies and gentlemen
you guys remember a couple months ago
John can't be a Christian Harlow and I
we teamed up at Flappers comedy live in
Burbank to talk Ant-Man and the lost
Quantum Mania spoilers it was one of the
best moments of my YouTube career ended
up talking with so many fans during the
show and after it was such a highlight
so we thought we'd re-team again for
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. so on
Sunday May 7th 5 o'clock p.m we are
returning to Flappers tickets are now
available we've already been selling and
it's been going great but also if you
can't make it in person which is the
ideal way to go you're also going to be
having pay-per-view links as well so you
can stream in love to have you in
attendance guys are you ready for this
last trailer let's go
[Music]
I lost my parents
we know
made me who I am
a whole lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back cool most of that is him
right yeah it must be you actually did
it oh
you actually did I can't imagine what
you've been through suit looks great
moving I love you monkey you lost both
parents in one day very
I went back in time to time just for my
parents
but instead
I completely broke the universe
this world must die
you changed the future
stands for
it's hope right
how did you know that I will help you if
I thought
you want to get nuts
sweets two flashes right there confirmed
I have to undo what I did
guardrail
gotta let her go I think it's who we are
I'm about to go back and fix them yes
a Metro tragedy to find you
man this is so harrowing
oh
awesome yeah
Batman consonant look at him go do
We're not gonna be it's this
interesting damn holy awesome yes
[Music]
that's great that's great you're
strapped to your parachutes and where's
yours
a Batman
[Music]
no so much bad symbolism oh right in
front of the Moon Man how beautiful
gorgeous film love it I love that hell
and the Flash dude is so pretty every
time I think we should go frame by frame
ladies and gentlemen I think we should
remember the first time we saw the
trailer we didn't know for sure if this
was him but this must be him when they
first show up and then he gets a
bitching billionaire haircut that's how
it's done so that way he can look like
that that's right be a whole montage
where he's crying as they're cutting his
hair it looks like fanfic brought to
life it just gives you so much joy of
nostalgia okay so these suits think
they're all the same but that blue and
gray is so perfect on the left which one
this one yeah yeah second from the left
I hope we see it in action me too what's
so great about this particular shows the
first one was so fun this leaned more on
that grief element that Barry is
struggling with and I loved the
identification that they hone in on with
both Batman and the Flash uh equality
that you know they both lost their
parents a very superhero quality to you
have to endure this really shows you
that heart that I feel like Andy
muschietti would be actually great at
bringing a life while bringing spectacle
into the equation too because at the end
of the day what makes a lot of these
superhero movies when they're truly
great is having that level of emotion
and heart and I thought this trailer
honed in on that perfectly and the
dichotomy between Batman like going
towards grief and Vengeance and
eventually him getting towards optimism
and hope I love that Barry is so
optimistic through this and he I mean he
like he says he succeeds he did save his
parents through fighting crime but then
he has to unwrite it he has to undo the
thing Batman's always tried to do but we
know he's not going to we know he'll
make the right call in the end he's
going to shoot his mom in the head
of his bare hands to undo the success he
has to end the thing that was the
accomplishment that's brutal one and for
as much of a meme as it is of it like oh
man this is shaping up to be a real
Batman movie like it does make a lot of
thematic sense and I'm excited for how
they hone in more personally on that
debate between the two of them about you
know what to do with a timeline and you
know holding on to that memory of your
parents to such a degree that you would
go to this extent did we get a look at
the speed force before in the last
trailer I think really briefly this is
much longer look we can see the Matrix
like bullet time around it which I don't
think we saw yeah I'm trying to see if
we can catch any little glimpses in here
as I remembered and like what is this
thing forming right there at the end is
he just uh I look like a it looks like a
little ghost of him I could I couldn't
tell if it was like a creature or
something like that turning into a
phoenix but I do think there's a
symbolism right here or it looks like it
looks like an actual design of something
is appearing right here he's passing
through a Sonic ring that's also I would
say in this we're going to see a lot of
flashes of Elder multiverses though I
think we're just they're cutting away
but there's going to be images I think
we're going to get other worlds in that
sequence yeah one at the very end it has
the blue Lightning so I wonder if that's
like symbolic of this flash with the
yellow lightning arriving in the
timeline I'm almost familiar with or
something like that oh that makes sense
and the classic slide is so great I love
that yeah these look like iMac shots
seriously I recognize an IMAX camera and
the recontextualization of all the Man
of Steel stuff is a really cool like
going really in depth with that in this
trailer is I didn't realize like how
much this is going to be sort of like oh
just on the other side of this situation
you know not to open it up because I'm
scared to but what if this is so good
not only do they keep Ezra but it does
allow for the Snyder world to exist as a
parallel timeline because this looks
like it could either end it or allow for
it which is interesting well the one
thing that I'm really hoping for that
they do here is because Zod looks like
the bad guy again and it feels like this
is you know they're they're doing Man of
Steel remake at this point but I'm
wondering if the movie will allow time
to flesh out Zod or have Zod be
something different or interesting
because you're gonna kind of compare his
presence here to what he did at Man of
Steel and he's just gonna be is did they
just bring back Michael Shannon to
rehash you know what he already did but
on a much smaller level and when looking
at the destruction because it's like
this is the destruction within the city
but later on in the trailer and
especially this moment looks like they
they fight actually out in the desert
yeah where there are no people yeah
smart call Smart call sociality learning
from the message boards
that line again to have uh Supergirl say
hope is is or imply that's the symbol is
wonderful because I I really think
there's a presence to her I'm excited to
see on screen oh yeah I mean there's
even these tight little glimpses she
just looks like such an intense
character at least in this
representation and I can't wait to see
what Sasha Kelly does with it it's
pretty cool that they brought this line
back
your Felix one I love it because it
gives me the warmth but two it what he
says that it's Bruce Wayne and it's at
the Joker it's out of context it makes
no sense logically but it's okay cause
it's fun I don't know who he's saying it
to not the Joker I wonder if it's
because in the flashpoint comic is when
uh you know Batman tries to help him get
his powers back Barry Allen ah the
electricity scenes that I've seen
because it seems like through it it is
circumstances that at some point both of
them will have powers both berries will
have the flash Powers
um and I wonder if that's what he's
talking about is like I'm gonna strike
you yeah I'm gonna raise you into my bat
Frankenstein you know Inspire yeah
because yeah you got like two very
different flash suits here I love them
roided out one it's got a bat cowl flash
she's wearing a bat suit painted red
yeah
and he's got the yellow like that's
basically a street sign drawn on so this
is bat flash on the right so I assume
this is The Flash this is our Flash from
Man of Steel time yeah and he's imported
into the world and that's the suit he
borrows because those are the ABS from
Batman Returns and he's got the blue
Lightning and he's got the yellow
lightning which is the release Credence
to your theory about the lightning
Landing yeah and Credence good uh
reference to another Ezra Miller
character ah slowing this footage down
Supergirl's taking Barry up I I wonder
if
she's trying to help him get his powers
here I wonder if it fails in the Batman
version yeah and Supergirl brings him
straight to the source I'm like why the
hell is she bringing him up to the sky
straight straight into the stratosphere
um we need to find the nearest
thunderstorm we got lightning in there
too so I feel like he's he's trying to
help him get his powers back there or he
dies and they have to jolt him back to
life like it he looks very unconscious
like like he dies doing the experimental
way and she has to bring him up and it
gets to work oh yeah yeah yeah we need
more lightning
Organics like free range lightning and
the blue and orange here is gorgeous
just from like a visual aesthetic style
because you've got all these blue and
oranges with the two flashes but the
explosion here with the Kryptonian
technology in the Earth Technology
clashing so you've got blue and orange
this force field you got blue and orange
the explosion you've got like this is
just gorgeous yeah it's true a nice
thematic earmark yeah this looks
freaking torturous he was trying to get
his powers back and in Flashpoint they
have to do it a few times so it's going
to be rough when I do appreciate
appreciate the in this imagery they do
keep still some of that Snyder aesthetic
like especially when he's screaming and
being Zapped by lightning like that
looks like something straight out of
zsjl or something like that you know
so even though it's not like clear that
that's still part of the universe
they're still homogening it pretty
heavily that's why I'm wondering if
they're going to keep the universe going
through this and and like I was talking
about the multiple flashes here I love
that they've a long-haired flash
symbolizing one ideal of Flash and then
the short air flash but you've also got
that with the Batmans like we just saw
Ben Affleck talking about his grief and
his experience then we've got Michael
Keaton on his knees soon thereafter so
the duality of Batman's with the way
vengeance is what they became but the
berries optimism is what he became so
you you've got a vengeful long-haired
Berry and then you've got Arbury who
discovers hope through adversity but
Batman never found that fully which is a
really beautiful dichotomy between a
pair of flashes and a pair of bats
yeah you know what uh Batman would
totally die in this fight I don't care
what anyone says but it's cool looking I
took care of it he's got
three there's several kryptonians yeah
he didn't even totally died this guy's
like 90. and he's like yeah
this guy would survive oh In This Moment
here oh yeah doing the doing the Locust
film bumper version of all the different
uh uh Justice League logos
and then the error cut will be the
post-credits scene it'll be great did
you catch that look at that oh 100 that
was I was focused on Batman diving there
oh yeah that moonshot is gorgeous uh
that's a great shot yeah well that's
straight from the 89 movie yeah and and
this has so much of both the movie
history of the Batman stories but also
it just has so many shots that really
feel like that Darth Gothic dark Gothic
comic book sort of vibe too along with
all the stuff that hearkens to the
Snyder works and moshietti I said it was
the first trailer but he grabs a comic
frame and makes it happen and he did Tim
Burton with Batman he's doing Snyder win
his cider scenes but also the mushitti's
clearer in this trailer like you said
with the grief there's a lot more of
mushitti's Style mixed with Snyder's
mixed with Burtons to make this great
splash page stunning all right guys well
what'd you think about this trailer for
The Flash are you excited are you
prepared to read all the leaks that come
out after Cinema con already airs is for
so many people are you ready to mute
every single related word on Twitter
guys get ready for it Jesus
well leave your thoughts down below uh
be sure to subscribe leave a like if you
want to attend uh the event that I'm
doing that would be very much
appreciated follow this guy on social
media I'll see you guys soon
[Music]